my family is close to paying off for a
mortgage and then we are completely
debt-free will you please give
perspective on our world events talking
about the Israel at War Etc what's the
best advice to prepare financially for
our own home and how to invest with so
much turmoil whenever there's Calamity
whenever there's uncertainty in the
world I think about coid and all those
things uh I really go quickly to
controlling what I can control and in
this case like you said you're close to
paying off your mortgage you're close to
being completely debt free do those
things that you know to do and continue
walking down that path and um and then
for me I just also have to accept it's
like in one hand I control the things
that I can control and then on the other
hand I have to accept the things that I
can't control